PRESENTER: Stucco is one
of the oldest construction
materials on the planet.
The earliest formulations
date back to ancient Greece
and Mayan Mexico.
Stucco has stuck around.
And as an exterior siding,
it's come a long way.
Modern stucco is more attractive
and offers better protection.
Whether cement or
acrylic-based, stucco always
starts out as a sticky
paste, and that's
the great thing about stucco.
In this wet and
gooey form, it can
be worked as it's applied to
the exterior of a building
to achieve a
variety of textures.
It hardens to provide
a tough exterior
that shields the building
against the elements.
To mass produce
cement stucco, they
start with tons of silica sand.
They unload it into a
conveyor and elevator
system which delivers the
sand to silos for storage
until needed.
They select sand with
various grades of coarseness
for different stucco finishes.
They mix it with cement,
lime, and other ingredients
to create the stucco base.
A technician demonstrates how
the ingredients come together
using this research lab mixer.
She blends all the
ingredients dry,
achieving a consistency that's
similar to cake mix from a box.
Cement stucco is
sold in dry form.
Water will be added to
liquefy the ingredients
on the job site.
In this demonstration,
she also adds pigment.
With a stucco
pre-colored, there's
no need to paint the building.
To mass produce cement stucco,
they use this mega mixer.
The operator adds three
or four different pigments
to create a custom color
in the dry stucco batch.
Large paddle blades
spiral vigorously.
Usually, this is a
closed operation,
but they've opened
it up for our camera.
After three minutes of
mixing, the dry stucco mix
is ready for scrutiny.
An employee takes a sample
and sends it to the quality
control lab for evaluation.
At the lab, the technician
weighs the stucco mixture
and adds water.
He keeps an eye on the scale
to ensure that the amounts are
proportionate.
He mixes them and
visually checks
to confirm that the
pigment and raw materials
are well dispersed.
Acrylic stucco,
on the other hand,
calls for an entirely
different recipe.
They use calcium
carbonate instead
of silica sand and acrylic as
a binder instead of cement.
They mix it with water and
sell it wet in a bucket
instead of dry.
To color it, they use
a computerized tint
machine similar to what
you find in a paint store.
They load the machine
with liquid pigments
and enter a color formula
into the computer.
It mixes the pigments to
produce the exact color,
and it releases the
precise amount needed.
They blend the color
into the acrylic stucco,
and the batch ends up
looking like blue mud.
It's now ready to
apply to a home--
no prep required.
They also sell acrylic
stucco with no color at all.
It's called tint base.
The pigments will be
added on the job site
where they can be
adjusted if needed.
An airtight seal keeps the
stucco in its fascia state.
Acrylic stucco dries
quickly like paint,
while cement stucco takes
28 days to totally cure
into a more durable finish.
Over on the cement stucco
line, a rotating machine
handles all the packaging.
A suctioning device pulls a
paper bag into position under
a spout which then fills it up.
It takes just eight seconds
to fill a 90-pound bag.
That works out to over
1,300 bags per hour--
enough material for 30 houses.
The machine transfers the
bag to the conveyor belt.
This stucco is now ready
to provide a strong finish
to building projects.
Applied to a building's
exterior, stucco
can be textured to suit
the homeowner's taste,
and it will harden to provide
the building with a tough skin.
That's why stucco continues to
be part of the urban landscape.